turning to Iran now where supreme leader
Ayatollah Khamenei has said the West
couldn't stop Iran from building nuclear
weapons even if it wanted to during an
address on state television he also
spoke about how his country should
continue to work alongside the un's
nuclear Watchdog and that a deal was
possible but as long as Iran's nuclear
energy infrastructure remained intact
they say they are concerned about
nuclear weapons they lie they know that
we are not after a nuclear weapon the
security apparatus of the U.S repeatedly
announced that Iran is not getting off
to nuclear weapons over the past few
months twice they confess that there is
no sign that Iran is moving toward
building a nuclear weapon and this is
true well we are not after getting a
nuclear weapon not because we are afraid
of them this is because of our belief
that it is used for mass killing and we
oppose that it is contradictory to our
religion we are against either nuclear
or chemical weapons or any other weapons
of mass destruction our correspondent
dorsage Bari is following developments
for us in Tehran
Ayatollah Ali Harmony was
addressing a group of high-ranking
officials within his compound here in
the capital that work on Iran's nuclear
program he was presented with the latest
achievements in Iran's nuclear
activities by these officials and he
took the occasion to speak extensively
and we heard from the 84 year old for
the first time acknowledging that Iran
has the capabilities to build a nuclear
weapon but it does not want to do so it
is unislamic as he said and it's
something that is not in the works for
this country he also took the occasion
to tell the officials to continue their
cooperation with the international
atomic energy agency but not at the cost
of going against the laws that are in
place inside the country he also took
the chance to talk about any kind of a
deal that could be in the works or that
could come in the near future is okay
with him but it means not at the expense
of stopping Iran's nuclear advancements
meaning that any kind of a deal would be
more beneficial to Iran rather than
Western Powers it's very unlikely that
the Western Powers would accept such
conditions given that the 2015 nuclear
deal that was signed saw Iran basically
limit severely its nuclear activities in
exchange for sanctions relief and that
deal is no longer working so there's a
lot of chatter about a possible interim
deal with the United States but that
seems to be very unlikely given the
current climate in the country and what
we just heard from
Ayatollah
well let's bring in Mohammed mirandi
he's a professor at the University of
Tehran and he joins us now by Skype from
the Iranian Capital Muhammad this isn't
the first time I believe that we've seen
Khamenei say that Iran is capable of
building a nuclear weapon but it sounded
from his comments like he was drawing
lines boundaries around his
non-negotiables and any kind of talks
you're absolutely correct he has said
this on a number of occasions in over
the past few years and I think a while
back for the former foreign minister Dr
Kamal kharozzi said this in uh Doha
Qatar as well uh
what he's basically telling the the webs
is that Iran is not intimidated by their
threats and that they cannot force Iran
to give up its Sovereign right he said
before as well that if Iran wanted to
develop nuclear weapons it could have
done so many years ago and the reason
why Iran hasn't pursued nuclear weapons
is because Iran doesn't believe in them
and I think there is strong evidence for
this during the 1980s when Western
European countries Germany and others
were giving Saddam Hussein chemical
weapons to use extensively against
Iranians I suffered I survived two of
those attacks and when the United States
was giving military intelligence and the
political cover to Saddam to get away uh
to to escape any political repercussions
Iran did not retaliate either when
people went to the leader to speak about
developing chemical weapons back then uh
the leader at that time among Romania
Ayatollah Khomeini said no we don't
believe in this so his
fatwa is in accordance with the fat wall
of
it's interesting though because we're
now I believe hearing that the U.S and
Iran held indirect talks in Oman last
month yesterday we saw the release of
some Iranian funds from Iraq now just
days ago as well it was reported that
Iran's U.N Ambassador had also met with
Rob Maley the USS special Envoy to Iran
I believe that took place on on U.S soil
what's behind this increased engagement
direct talks have not taken place
between Iran and the United States
indirect talks and the passing of
messages have been going on for quite a
while and you know that there are more
there are a number of issues there's a
nuclear issue there there's a nuclear
negotiations that took place last year
there's the issue of prison prisoner
exchange because we have prisoners help
abroad because of the United States and
they are prisoners in Iran and uh and
and of course the Iranian assets that
have been illegally withheld in
different countries and of course there
are those countries that need to have
those assets freed Iraq owes Iran more
than 10 billion dollars because of the
electricity that Iran has provided and
the natural gas and the Iranian leader
again and the Iranian government don't
want to cut that gas even though they or
the electricity even though they owe
Iran so much because they don't want
harm to come to ordinary Iraqis but this
is not sustainable forever so the Iraqis
are also putting pressure on the United
States and Korea they their relations
with China are being harmed because of
the United States and relations with
Russia are very poor because of the
United States and because of the fact
that they're holding Iranian assets
their relations are very poor with Iran
as well so the Koreans are putting
pressure on the Americans for those
assets to be released so you have
different forces at play and we have to
see what happens as a result of all of
these different forces coming together
very interesting Dynamics indeed there
the Mohammad Morandi the professor at
the University of Tehran thank you for
sharing your insights with us here on Al
Jazeera